hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
towards the end of section 2 of his
groundwork of the metaphysics of morals
among you'll can spend some time talking
about other principles of morality all
of which ultimately come back to what he
calls heteronomy of the will and we'll
talk about that in a moment but you
notice that on the board here we've got
a number of different principles or
essentially grounds for moral theories
set out for them
and what we're going to do is talk about
each of them first we're going to talk
about what each of them is what it is
that they say morality consists in then
we'll talk about Kant's criticisms of
each of these and why they end up being
a type of heteronomy and then we'll
finish by talking about what sort of
ordering Kant gives to them he says that
that they're all bad but some of them
are less bad or at least better in some
respects than the other ones so what is
heteronomy to begin with heteronomy is
opposed to autonomy which is when the
will gives itself its own determination
and for Kant determination in terms of
morality that is in terms of our duties
and what we ought to do and what the
good is all these sorts of things he
conceives of this in terms of laws or
rules norms if you if you like so to be
autonomous means not only to choose for
yourself or to determine yourself but
it's to actually give yourself laws to
give yourself the principles the guiding
norms by which you are going to make
moral decisions and engage in moral
action so what does heteronomy that well
in heteronomy instead of the will
deciding for itself or the person
through their will deciding for
themselves instead you have some sort of
object and it's the objects as he says
relation to the will providing it with
some sort of inducement some sort of
interest appealing to for example the
Wills liking this
particular thing or being drawn by
desire or by inclination that is what
determines the will so quite literally
it's you know law or rule by by another
heteros means other and so Kant says
there's four main ways in which we can
distinguish the moral principles by
which a person would have a heteronomous
will he says that two of these are what
he calls empirical that is based on our
experience there that based on some some
things that we encounter in experience
and then draw from from them and then
two of them are what he calls rational
which means that they appeal to things
that go beyond the realm of our
experience and they're not for that that
matter necessarily false or anything
like that but they are not found solely
within our experience so what are these
on the side of the empirical we have he
first says individual or it can be
translated sometimes as private or
personal eigen in happiness and Kant has
a particular conception of happiness
happiness is the satisfaction of all of
our inclination and desires that is what
he thinks happiness consists in so that
is one thing what would that be as a
moral theory or as a principle would say
well you should do what is actually
going to make you happy so you should
behave in a good way because that's
actually going to make you happy they'll
make you you know successful or people
will like you or you won't get in
trouble so that's that's that theory
then Conte says there's also moral
feeling right gufu in in german a very
similar sense but this is what we would
talk about in terms of feeling
compassion or sympathy or to use a word
that people love to throw around these
days empathy and there were indeed some
moral theories that were basing
themselves at least in part on the
notion of sympathy Hume and
Adam Smith talked about this
jean-jacques rousseau thinks that this
plays an important role in morality so
you have some representatives of this
then on the other side of the rationale
what he calls the principle of
perfection we're dealing with something
that's a bit more metaphysical or a bit
more abstract and he talks first about
the principle of perfection full kommen
height in German and here we would think
about many of what we typically call
today virtue ethics you know ethics of
personal realization of becoming the
best you any of those sorts of things
those would be what he's calling this
principle of perfection and the idea is
that there's some sort of you know
either
it's human nature as such or it's and
you know the reality is such and you
want to realize the the you know full
potential of it and come to the fully
developed State for the kind of being
that we are that is human being then the
fourth we have a Divine Will or command
something to coming to us from God or
the gods or however else we conceive of
as the divine and it tells us what we
ought to do why is this placed under the
principle of perfection well because
it's understood as coming from a
divinely perfect will in this case we're
trying to have a divinely perfect will
in this case there's some sort of
divinely perfect will out there that
were somehow tapping into or fortunate
enough to receive a revelation by now
all of these are problematic according
to Kant why are they problematic let's
start at the bottom again with
individual happiness Kant says that look
at the moral theory it's just false to
begin with right it says that prosperity
or doing well or success or you know
getting what it is that you want is
somehow proportion to good conduct and
all you have to do is have a bit of
experience to know that's not actually
true there are bad people who do prosper
in the world there are good people who
have terrible outcomes
sometimes precisely by being good and
having the bad people do things to them
so it's false to begin with worse than
that Kant thinks that it actually
undermines morality by providing us with
the wrong sort of inducements so when
we're telling children hey you need to
behave so that people will like you you
need to behave so you won't be punished
or you need to behave so I'll give you
some candy or you need to behave so
Santa Claus will bring you candy or
whatever we're really screwing them up
according to count we're giving them the
wrong inducements and giving them a
false principle to work by when we come
to the the other principle of happiness
that a moral feeling kind of has a few
other things to say they all essentially
boil down to you cannot base morality on
feeling
why can't you base morality on feeling
because it's an uncertain guide it's not
a reliable guide to morality you might
feel one way at one moment and then feel
another way at another moment some
people don't seem to have a lot of moral
feelings this can't be an adequate guide
plus you can't expect that people are
going to have the right feelings you
can't you can't tell somebody feel
sympathy I mean you can tell them it's
just not going to produce the result
that you want so this is not going to be
a particularly effective guide Kant says
one other thing about it too this is a
substitute for people who don't want to
think and would rather just feel when it
comes to morality he sees that as a bad
thing now when it comes to these other
parts he says the problem with the
principle of perfection is that you know
it's ontological but it's empty its
indefinite we don't really know what it
means to say that a human being would
develop you know to the greatest degree
possible or fulfill their potential or
anything along these lines in part
because that that's a indeterminate
notion it could mean a lot of different
things he says another issue is trying
to distinguish the reality that we're
speaking from every other we end up kind
of going in a circle this this ends up
being very murky and so counsel that's
not going to be an adequate guide for us
either
then when it comes to the Divine Will or
command can't says look we don't
actually have any intuition of divine
perfection we don't know what a divinely
perfect will would be so we end up
relying upon our own ideas
in doing so this leads to all sorts of
problems he says we can only deduce it
from our own conceptions so either we're
deriving it from moral conceptions we
think of God as being like super you
know suit super good and all that which
is fine but then let's just you rely on
morality itself and not to do that or we
rely on conceptions like you know desire
glory Dominion might vengeance all those
sorts of things and in that case Khan
says look if you're going to try to
establish a system morality on those
grounds you're actually going very far
away from morality you may as well in
that case you know just go for the
private happiness because as bad as that
is it's not as bad it's it's over here
and so that leads us to the third thing
kana thinks that this appeal to the
Divine Will is is you know really off
based it's going to lead us astray
remember to that count is indeed writing
after centuries of religious warfare in
Europe so you know recent experience of
that sort of thing he says that if we
have to choose between principles of
happiness we should go with moral
feeling that's better at least than is
individual happiness why because moral
feeling at least acknowledges that
there's something desirable about
morality in itself whereas this says no
morality it's just there so that you
stay out of trouble get the things that
you want
what's really good is the things that
you want right this actually in an
inchoate way recognizes it and likewise
the you know the principle of you might
call it development of the human person
at least recognizes something and it's
sort of on the way to autonomy but not
there so all of these fit into different
types of heteronomy and none of them
according to cut can furnish us with an
adequate ground or principle for
morality
you